this city is no stranger to explosions
but absolutely nothing
like this nothing like this before let
me just give you a taster of
of what they're waking up to this
morning everywhere you look
there are devastated buildings this is
in the heart of germaisy it's one of the
most
uh congested areas it's one of the
busiest areas this
this area was full of people last night
when uh the explosions happened almost
every for streets and streets around
this is devastation wherever you look i
mean we can't even show you how high
of the area is let's try and cross
across the
the road load of people are just trying
to get out of
of the city but look look at the state
of some of the the businesses
just many of them reduced to rubble
um if we ever maybe have a chat to these
people and see if um
morning morning guys do you talk english
yes
tell me where were you last night when
the um explosion first happened
we weren't here
we were sitting home you're sitting at
home lucky for you
are you connected to this business yeah
it's my shop
well it's pretty devastated it's okay at
least we're alive we're still alive
we're thankful that we're still alive at
the end of the day
it's not just me it's all of lebanon you
know everyone
is having its share its own share of
this tragedy you know
so it's okay i'm just trying to convey
to the viewers back in
in britain who you're broadcasting to
now just how big this is
and how shocked everyone was here at
this
i mean you've not seen anything like it
no we're still on the shop that's why
we're still trying to
you know get we sit back to get to know
what's happening we don't know what's
happening
we don't know if this explosion is
it's uh something if it's uh done
on purpose or it's just an accident
a lot of uncertainty i live near the
embassy and outside my home
was rambling do you mind if we have a
look at your business quickly come come
and show us
what it's like and we'll show you i mean
a lot of it is very
um uncertain around here there's a lot
of uh
hanging buildings whole balconies
disappeared i mean
you you as you as you say you're
actually you've still got
product in there which is still standing
i mean some some people have lost
everything yes yeah and they're having
we just locked the doors as you see and
uh
it's not it's not that major it's minor
but compared to many others yes yes yeah
if you walk in jamaica
amazing it's like a desert right now
yeah we're just at the edge of jamaica
you know yeah it is like a war zone yeah
people said when it
went off many people spoke about it
likening it to a nuclear bomb
exactly hydrogen bomb not the nuclear
bomb
it's so powerful it was so powerful
i don't know if it's a bomb or a mistake
fabrication mistake or something good at
the board
but i think it's a bomb for sure it's a
bomb well thank you very much for
talking to us thank you
we'll just show you another street i
mean they've brought the um
uh the soldiers out to try and maintain
law in order to try and keep
the peace and also because many people
are worried about looting because
lebanon
look here another another street
devastated
we'll be bringing you updates uh
throughout the morning and trying to
show you more
about the huge devastation that this
city has suffered after
decades of conflict already
you